NICK TAYLOR: Hello, thanks
for joining us today.
We're going to be
talking about building
a large-scale migration
factory in Google Cloud.
My name is Nick Taylor
and I'm [INAUDIBLE]
lead for migration in our
professional services team.
And with me today is Ben.
BEN HAGAI: Hey,
everyone, Ben Hagai here.
I'm the migration
global practice
lead for professional
services organization.
NICK TAYLOR: Thanks, Ben.
So we're going to talk about
three steps in building
a large-scale
migration factory in
and how to get that
infrastructure into GCP.
First of those steps is
building a business case,
so understanding the value of a
migration, why you're doing it,
and what you're able to
achieve for your business.
Step two is about
establishing foundations,
both technical
and non-technical,
and preparing for scale,
picking those first applications
and getting some
infrastructure moved.
And then the third step is
about scaling the factory,
so how to industrialize
the process,
move large volumes of workloads.
So first off, building
that business case.
Even though it's almost
inevitable you'll
save money with a cloud
migration any effort--
any change requires effort
and that means cost.
So we need to understand really
where the value realization is
and how you're going to save
money and gain efficiencies
in [INAUDIBLE] migration.
So let's take a look
at how we understand
the value of that migration.
So it's true to say that
the majority of IT budgets
are allocated today to
maintaining the status quo,
looking after your
current infrastructure.
So what we need
to think about is
how we can lower your
run costs to free up
money for innovation.
Migrations are
always disruptive,
so it's important to get
executive sponsorship
in driving that migration.
And demonstrating
those savings are
a good step in that process.
So we think about building
a migration-- a return
on investment calculation.
We look at your as-is run rate.
So what are you spending
today on infrastructure,
on maintaining your
infrastructure,
and on software
licensing, on people
who manage that
infrastructure, also the assets
themselves-- data centers,
land, rent, things like power?
On the other side, we
compare that with what
the likely to-be spend is.
So what's the anticipated
ramp of spend in GCP?
What would it cost you to get
the migrations moved over?
And what does the
timeline look like
to decommission your
existing infrastructure?
So when will you start
to realize that value?
When we look at your
current run costs,
we think about the inventory
of your infrastructure
and understand it from a
real sort of fact-based way
where you're spending
today and how you how easy
it will be to do the migration.
So we use inventory
tooling for that.
You can see examples of some
of our preferred partners
on the screen.
Those tools will look at
the servers themselves,
so what's their size and
shape, CPU, memory, and so on?
And also how well they utilized
as well as the dependencies
in between them.
This tooling will also look
at things like storage,
networking, security costs.
And you need to consider
things like logging
and backups as well.
And we add into those
supporting costs--
building maintenance, power
cooling, software licensing,
and so on--
as we build the cost model.
Then we think about
the other side
of the business
case, which is how
you are going to realize value?
How you're going to
drive efficiencies
through cloud migration?
The first of these is
infrastructure optimization.
And grid computing is a
great example of this.
Imagine risk calculations
that run for eight hours
overnight, five days a week.
So your production
environment, then,
is idle for 16 hours
a day during the week
and often the complete weekend.
Meanwhile, your disaster
recovery environment
is idle the whole time.
So actually you're barely
using your infrastructure.
We've seen banks that
made 18% savings when
they moved those
calculations to the cloud
by just using
infrastructure on demand
without making any changes
to their applications.
Although less magnified, that's
true for disaster recovery
in general.
And you don't need a full-sized
DR environment always running.
You can spin that up as
you need it in the cloud.
There are other savings
here for infrastructure,
things like storage
optimization,
considering backup
strategy, and just adjusting
your infrastructure [INAUDIBLE].
The second thing to consider
here is operational efficiency.
So Google Cloud gives
consolidated availability
and performance
running-- monitoring
of all the infrastructure
that you've deployed.
And, similarly, we recommend
using infrastructure
as code for deployment of
both servers themselves
and all the supporting
infrastructure, firewalls,
and so on.
By doing so, you're realizing
significant operational
savings.
Also things like
automated patch management
and consolidating
security tooling
mean that you'll save further.
When you think about
modernizing applications,
that's the third step here,
and refactoring applications
to be cloud native.
It means we'll take advantage
of both of those things, just
infrastructure when
you need it and also
the operational efficiency
of continuous deployment
and consolidated cloud
native [INAUDIBLE]..
So when we bring all
those things together,
we build a complete value model
for your cloud migration, both
the current and
future operating costs
gathered from
tooling and then data
from across the organization on
the benefits the top can bring.
Together, those things
show your expected returns.
You'll see here there's a bit
of a hump for migration cost,
inevitably as you're dual
running infrastructure
and perhaps paying for
services, whether ours
or a partner or even just
your own timing during that
migration.
But we can help you offset that
migration hump as you migrate
and maximize value
as early as you can.
So far we've spoken about cost
savings, but what other value
you can get by
migrating to the cloud?
Cloud migration helps you
unlock business value.
So as you've migrated
data into the cloud,
often you're seeing
queries take seconds
where they used to take days.
So that access to
real-time data enables
you to make more strategic
business decisions based
on real-time data and
also allows access
to that tooling, that data,
and to things like machine
learning across
your organization.
It also enables
business agility.
So we described that kind
of rapid software lifecycle
and continuous deployment,
and means typically lower time
to market for new features and
new innovation in the business.
And then finally,
Google Cloud is
one of the most robust,
so our global security
and our world-class network
used for our own products
is now available to
you, meaning there's
less likelihood of business
disruption from IT service
outages.
So you've thought about a
clear business case now.
You've got approval to move
forward with your migration.
What next?
So we start to look
at how to build
the foundations in the Cloud.
As you'd expect from
Google, we think about
migration more than
just about technology.
You might need to change your
organization as well, when
you're thinking about
adopting the Cloud to regain
the benefits.
We use the Google Cloud
adoption framework
as the core of our operating
model in the Cloud.
And how do you understand the
implications of that cloud
migration, how to get
the best out of it,
and what might need to
happen in your organization?
The Cloud adoption framework
is made of four key themes--
learn, lead, scale, and
secure-- that you see here
on the screen.
Learn means, of course,
learning new skills
in training and
technology, but it also
changes the way you learn.
Cloud resources are
cheap and disposable,
so it means people can
learn and innovate safely
through hackathons
and experimentation.
Leadership means, of course,
executive sponsorship
for the program
and a clear vision.
But it also means sharing
knowledge [INAUDIBLE]
practice across
the organization.
We recommend something like a
center of excellence or a Cloud
Platform team to
help achieve that
and this kind of psychological
safety and reduction of silos
across the organization as well.
Scale means using
Cloud adoption to build
repeatable, scalable processes.
So we talked about DevOps
and continuous integration,
and infrastructure
is covered here.
To me, it's much
easier for you to scale
vast quantities
of infrastructure
with less operational toil.
Security means
trust, really, trust
in the deployment of the Cloud.
We think typically that
Cloud security is stronger
than on-premise security.
But it's different.
You need to think about how
your security model will change.
So how do you know where you
are with those four key themes?
We take a gamble,
and we help you
do a Cloud Maturity Assessment
across each of the themes.
We'll look at
whether you're taking
a tactical, strategic, or
transformational view of Cloud
adoption.
So where are you
today, and how far
do you want to go as an
organization, and the change
that you might
want to undertake?
We'll help you make
recommendations, allow
you to set up your Cloud
team, and really get
the best out of the Cloud
as you start [INAUDIBLE]..
That assessment
can be undertaken
by asking our
professional services
team, through partners,
or you can do it yourself
using a self-service tool.
And the URL for that
is on the screen.
So once you've understood
that Cloud Maturity
and where you are
on those key themes,
you'll really start to
understand the operating model
you want to build in the Cloud.
So those translate into
those themes you see here
on the left of our platform
engineering and governance
and building our
operating model.
We take the lessons from
the Maturity Assessment
and build that Cloud Operating
Model for your organization.
It takes all those
themes and establishes
a set of controls
and services that
allow you to operate
comfortably in the Cloud.
Most of that, as
I mentioned, sits
in a Cloud Center of Excellence
team or Cloud Platform Team,
but spreads out across
the organization.
You'll see here
on the right where
that Cloud Center of Excellence
sits between your application
teams on the right and the Cloud
Infrastructure on the left.
If you're a DevOps
team, you might just
adopt the Cloud straight
away within those guardrails.
But for lots of
legacy applications
and the focus of
discussion today, we
recommend the
Migration Factory team,
that set of people and
processes that can help
migrate applications at scale.
So once you've built that
organizational structure,
we think about the
technical foundations
that you need based on
those controls that you've
defined to automate
the deployment
of your infrastructure.
So you need that secure place
to move your infrastructure
and consider whether it looks
like you're on premise estate
or whether it needs to
evolve, things like identity
management, security controls,
obviously, networking,
so establishing the
technical connectivity
between your own premise
environment and the Cloud,
but also the structure
of your network,
whether it looks like,
again, on premise,
whether you're using
new [INAUDIBLE]..
Instrumentation means
defining the baseline level
of your monitoring of
your infrastructure,
making sure it's available
and performs at least as
well as it did on premise
when you move it to the Cloud.
And finally, of course,
it's really important
to think about cost control.
It used to be that your
procurement department would
buy infrastructure or
approve that perhaps
once a year, whereas
in the cloud,
that's much more dynamic.
So understanding the impact of
that across your organization
is really important.
Remember, our focus to this
is as infrastructure as code.
We use our Cloud
Foundations Toolkit
as a common baseline set
of controls and automation
for deploying all of
that configuration.
It allows you to rapidly
deploy infrastructure, but also
all of the supporting
guardrails and controls.
Everything is then virtually
controled and really easy
to deploy.
If you choose not to do
that in an automated way
when you first get
started in GCP,
we also have an enterprise
on-boarding checklist,
which is a step-by-step
manual process
to help you establish similar
controls for your environment.
Once you've got that
environment all set up,
we help you evaluate
the migration path
for each of your workloads.
We have an overall approach
that's really four steps here--
assess, plan,
migrate, and optimize.
When we think about migration,
there are two key approaches.
For that re-hosting
and re-platforming,
we use our migration
factory approach, the focus
of our discussion today.
But we also think about
refactoring applications
and how you change
and modernize them.
So when we look at
that migration factory,
we can dive a little
bit deeper here
into how we undertake
that migration in scale
and organization.
So I'll hand over to Ben to
talk a little bit about scaling
that migration factory.
BEN HAGAI: Thank you, Nick.
So now that we have gone through
building the business case,
hopefully getting it approved,
we have a technical approach.
We made sure the technical and
the non-technical foundations
are ready.
It's time to get into
the actual migration.
For the actual
migration execution,
we often see enterprises adopt
the Migration Factory Program.
The Migration Factory teams will
manage the overall migration
process end to end.
The applications will
be migrated in what's
called migration waves.
The program and approach is
primarily driven top-down
within the organization,
and the factory's aim
is to maintain and accelerate
the migration velocity, running
parallel to migrate faster.
While we have arrived to an
overall technical approach,
each application will need
to have a detailed discovery
and assessment to make sure
nothing unexpected comes up.
And this is why you see in
each of these migration factory
waves, we have an
assess and plan stages
for their specific
applications being
migrated in that specific wave.
To get started, you will build a
small and agile pilot migration
team.
We usually call
the migration team
a pod or a migration squad.
It needs to have
a representation
from the key people
that will be needed
or from the key teams that
will be needed to achieve
a successful migration.
Think application engineers,
IT, product, business people,
et cetera.
To scale, and as you mature,
some of these functions
will move from the
migration party itself
to the larger extended migration
team or to the large COE.
Functions like security,
engineering, business,
now doesn't have to be inside
a specific migration pod.
And eventually, we see those
migration pods and the maturity
of the migration execution work
driven by IT and operations.
Application migration planning.
This is one of the
most important tasks
for the migration team.
Without proper planning, the
migration might be at risk.
We generally see
large organizations
re-hosting about 80%
of their workloads
initially, focusing their
transformation efforts in areas
where they can maximize impact.
But keep in mind that workloads
that have already moved to GCP,
even if they were moved
with a simple re-hosting,
can later on be
modernized to leverage
more Cloud-native services
in a much easier way.
The plan you build for the
specific application migration
or application component
migration at this stage
might be defer from the
default path, and even
within the default
migration strategy
that you have defined,
the various patterns that
can be used.
For example, if you
chose re-hosting, OK,
that might be re-hosting
into Google Compute Engine,
GCE, re-hosting into Google
Cloud [INAUDIBLE] engine,
GCVE, re-hosting
with OS upgrade,
re-hosting to Bare
Metal, et cetera.
Defining of a
specific application,
application component,
migration path,
is the primary outcome
of the base phase.
You should take the overall
strategy for the project--
for the program together
with the specific application
data points achieved through
automated discovery, CMDB,
and information from
key stakeholders
gathered through interviews
and questionnaires
to decide what's the best
path for this application.
We continue by going into the
next level of technical details
on the migration.
How will this specific
application migration
be executed?
Breaking down to
more and more details
until we are
comfortable that we have
a well-defined viewpoint
on how this migration is
going to take place.
Think pre- and post-migration
activities, testing strategy,
automation that should be
prepared in advance, et cetera.
In parallel to this
technical deep dive,
you should plan also further
planning on the migration
timing, taking
into consideration
technical dependencies as
well as business dependencies,
like change freezes,
planned releases,
with the goal of ultimately
defining to the greatest
possible degree when exactly
is a base application going
to be migrated.
Identifying what will be the
first workload to migrate
is critical.
I can't stress
enough how important
it is to get it right.
And when I say
getting it right, it
doesn't only mean a workload
to be migrated successfully.
You want it to be
a workload that
is a good representation of
your typical business workload,
not too simple, an
application that you
can build up documentation
and learn lessons from.
Think back.
What was the main migration
goals of the project?
Ideally, a first mover
that will show the value
correlated to these goals.
It can be improved performance.
It can be lower cost.
Something that is
measurable and will
make it worthwhile for the
business to stay engaged.
You can see various
other considerations.
And a lot can be
discussed on this topic,
but if I had to summarize
it in one sentence,
a good first mover will
have a high business value
but low effort to implement.
And when we talk about
low effort to implement,
automated tools are here
to help you with that.
They can assign a migration
fit score automatically,
taking into consideration
various factors like operating
system, performance, age, role,
dependencies count, et cetera.
We have talked a lot about
people and processes.
But the migration factory cannot
be complete without a very
mature technical angle.
Google has a variety
of technologies
to accelerate
migration of workloads
with an emphasis on automation.
Our migration
factory methodology
works alongside
tools such as Migrate
for Compute Engine,
Migrate for Anthos,
or data migration tools.
Through our tools
and technologies,
we seek to maximize
value to the business
through accelerating your
migration while minimizing
risk and complexity.
Migrate for Compute Engine will
be the factory's primary tool
for the migration execution.
It's built from the ground up
to enable accelerated migration
of VMs, physical servers, and
cloud machines into Google
Compute Engine.
It has all the
essential capabilities
to support the
factory, from built
in testing for your
VMs, automation tools
to drive mass migration
with minimal effort,
advanced networking, security
features, safe and fully
consistent migration and
rollback capabilities,
and it can even upgrade
Legacy Windows 2008 on the go.
With Migrate for Anthos,
customers can now automatically
migrate and modernize
existing workloads
running on prem, on other
clouds, or even GCE VMs
directly into containers
running on GKE or Anthos.
It's a fantastic
tool to those who
wish to migrate and
modernize, benefiting
from cost efficiencies,
benefiting
from modernized operations
management with the GKE
and Anthos advanced tools
like Service [? Mash, ?]
Tech Driver, and the Ecosystem,
benefiting from modernized app
lifecycle management for
maintenance, upgrades,
patching, overall,
increasing agility
for operations and developers.
Through the use of
Migrate for Anthos,
you can avoid some of the
common modernization challenges,
especially for those apps that
are not actively developed
or that you don't have access
to the source code, apps
that you want to modernize
fast without rewriting.
Optimization is always
a constant goal,
whether it is as simple as
computer optimization, where
we have numerous tools and
capabilities to help you reduce
costs, optimize performance and
operations, dozens of managed
services offerings that
can help you modernize
your applications incrementally
or overall, or application
modernization methodologies
and frameworks
for either existing or new apps.
All the way through
easy to use AI and ML
services that will allow you
to further embed innovation
faster.
So when we think on what
are some of the biggest
lessons learned from large scale
Migration Factory programs,
I think the first one
would be in that Cloud
means things can be redone.
Don't overplan.
One of the fundamental
benefits that we talked about
with the factory approach
is the agile execution,
the constant improvement.
Leverage that.
Focus on automation from the
foundations to migration,
deployment, controls,
automation is there to help you.
Testing both before and after,
have a well-defined view
of what you want to test and
who is going to do the testing,
and make sure you execute
it according to that plan.
Maintaining velocity is key.
Expect apps to move up
and down the backlog.
Be prepared for that.
And you can never have
too much communications
and business engagement.
Never underestimate the
meaning of those status
reports, status meetings,
and ongoing regular updates,
for the success of
the migration program.
We are in it together.
Now that you have learned more
about how to make the move,
how to build and scale
your Migration Factory,
you're likely asking
how you can get started.
Most enterprises choose not to
make this change alone and seek
for a partner to help them
with this migration journey.
At Google Cloud,
we have a variety
of ways to help you in
this journey, including
a broad and deep
network of partners,
our own specialist professional
services organization that
is working together
with this partner
ecosystem, a
comprehensive training
and enablement solutions,
and various documentations
to help you answer your
questions along the way.
So to recap, start with
building your business case.
Address current and future
costs as well as value and value
drivers.
Make sure it's driven by facts
rather than just assumptions.
Seek for a wide consensus to
drive your migration journey
forward.
Establish enterprise
foundations that
will allow you to scale
quickly both technical and
non-technical foundations, like
the Cloud Center of Excellence.
Scale your migration
factory, leveraging
the agile methodologies.
Iterate and improve
your efficiency.
Use the right tools
to migrate quickly.
And if you want
to learn more, we
have a collection of very
thoughtful white paper that
go further into the details
on data center transformation,
building a large scale
Migration Factory, et cetera.
Or, of course, feel
free to reach out
to your Google representative.
Thank you very much.